this is my first work class I'm so
excited
everybody were their best leggings Joe
Jesse
Joe Joe let's work this thing all right
see if things work out cards worth
getting yeah gotta work gotta charge
card
what do you mean I'm not attracted
anybody in here my genitals not
compatible with any human being
so please you're safe with me right now
we're gonna do the basics for the wobble
so run in place first
okay wobbling just let it change so
you're just moving the evacuator all
right long until you roll your hips can
you roll your head I cannot I know I can
do that yeah speed it up really fast I
go okay I cannot hurt my back my
vertebrae are in a parallel line and
they are fused together you know I
thought this is gonna be so stupid that
rule for women don't you take dry your
body shame in the next night I do find
it to be a human being
the but me to lean it yet at the same
time to take my
Jayla right